one of the most well known figures in
the college admissions scandal is due
back in federal court today
actress Felicity Huffman is expected to
plead guilty for her role in the largest
college admissions scheme ever
prosecuted Carter Evans is at the
federal courthouse in Boston Carter good
morning good morning Huffman is accused
of paying fifteen thousand dollars to
have a Proctor correct the answers on
her daughter's SATs but she was also one
of the first parents to agree to plead
guilty and analysts say that could work
in her favor Felicity Huffman is
expected to admit to a federal judge
today that she broke the law in a
statement the actress had expressed deep
regret and shame my daughter knew
absolutely nothing about my actions this
transgression toward her and the public
I will carry for the rest of my life
prosecutors have recommended Huffman pay
a twenty thousand dollar fine and serve
four to ten months behind bars Felicity
Huffman has been the model defendant in
this case the judge has every right and
ability to give her less than that
including probation and community
service or give her more than that
another parent expected to plead guilty
today is Devon Sloan prosecutors alleged
the Los Angeles businessman paid the
scheme's mastermind Rick singer $250,000
to get his son into USC as a waterpolo
recruit even though the teen didn't play
the sport when a high school guidance
counselor questioned the sports
credentials one of singers alleged
accomplices at USC stepped in
prosecutors say she then lied to the
admissions office in an email saying
Sloan's son was an attack perimeter
player who competed in summer leagues in
Italy Greece Serbia and Portugal
prosecutors say a guidance counselor
also raised red flags about the
applications for Lori Laughlin and
Massimo Jian Ulis daughters who were
admitted to USC as crew recruits but gia
newly allegedly met with the counselor I
shut down the concern what this shows is
that people who feel that they have rank
and privilege and money think that they
can do anything and that's what makes
people so upset about this case
Lachlan and Jia newly planned to plead
not guilty Huffman should be sent in
sometime in the next couple of months
and while their futures are uncertain
this story could live on in Hollywood
Noora production company is already
preparing to produce a miniseries I bet
they are Carter thank you so much